check this out Kamala Harris breaking
new barriers as vice president just not
the one she'd hope for Harris just
received the worst vice presidential
ratings in NBC News polling history just
32 percent of respondents held a
positive view of the vice president 49
said they held a negative opinion of her
and that gives Kamala a net net
favorability rating of -17 if I could do
my own math if you stack that number up
against previous VPS the picture is not
that pretty Mike Pence Dick Cheney and
Al Gore all seen as more favorable but
Harris does have one public cheerleader
who's that
I want to thank Kamala who's there for
every single important thing we do and
I'm not sure how we do it without her we
having kamlo's image is a top priority
for the White House and it better be
Biden's Chief of Staff praising her work
and saying quote I think the enthusiasm
and energy is palpable we just need to
make sure that we do a good job of
exposing her to the American public but
exposure may not be the problem
I'm going to tell you the Banger of the
summer okay okay that you need to play
for your people and they're gonna love
it everybody's gonna go crazy
[Music]
I like it yes this is the song in the
summer okay so you need to tell the DJ
to have that going okay okay all right
okay
okay you know I don't know if more
exposure is a good idea
did you see because man think about
Biden they were wearing the same two and
what was that about I don't know and she
was biting her lower lip like a white
guy
dancing at a wedding that is so
uncomfortable and awkward to watch I
mean it's almost as awkward as when John
Mayer was dating Taylor Swift
[Laughter]
that's actually more Awkward even now
yes but uh she is a historical figure
she is you know obviously the first
female vice president first woman of
color now the worst VP in history and
that's because of the first two the
first two got her in but that didn't
promise any competence or Excellence all
she had to do was tick those boxes and
unfortunately she didn't deliver the
rest which is like 10 to show up show up
do one thing a year that's all you gotta
do but she couldn't even do that so
that's why that's where they're at right
now they don't you know this she is kind
of the current state of the democratic
party she is the hood ornament you know
identity trumps competence uh and it
never reflects it you know and they
continually act like it's the 1850s or
the 1950s I'm sorry if you were if you
were a black black woman and you got an
education you have the golden key that
unlocks every door and when you get
inside and you can't achieve anything
that's on you by the way did you see the
other survey Dana what was that survey
this is amazing Reuters found out that
every single U.S president including
Barack Obama who is the descendant of
slave owners except for Donald Trump
so that means Obama has to pay
reparations but Trump doesn't
and there you have it you know what what
that's a good survey it is very
interesting judge one of the things that
we get about Kamala Harris is about once
a week There's a story maybe it's every
other week but it is a lot that they are
have a new plan and a new makeover and a
new plan to rehab her reputation and
this is now we're two and a half years
into the administration and so far not
working the amazing part of this is that
never in history has a position of vice
president but more important than it is
now should Biden be elected he'll be 82
at the time he's sworn in she is
literally a Heartbeat Away from the
presidency and with this negative vote
what is it 17 points 39 percent had very
negative feelings about her like hated
her it's not just negative with the 49
39 very negative she has an office with
a toxic work environment people are
fighting with each other to get to the
exit door this is a woman who was it was
in a position to make it easy for other
women behind her to come forward and do
the job where Americans could say you
know a woman is is capable of doing this
if anything she has established the the
precedent that a woman is incapable of
being vice president and John just look
at it with respect to what she's done I
mean you know the root causes at the
border and this nonsense that Joe's
trying to sell us that I couldn't do it
without Kamala I mean who is he kidding
so I guess the real question for them is
who do we let out Joe we don't know if
it's going to fall or if it's going to
stumble on his words or Kamala who just
laugh her way through the whole thing I
don't know what she's giggling about but
I have a philosophy in life and my
philosophy is if somebody is out there
always giggling they're a miserable
person but you get to work for them and
finally let me just say about
um setting records she do you remember
when they came out and she said Joe we
did it we did it when they won
it was so inauthentic there was
something about it that you just
couldn't buy so if they really want to
show Kamala Moore uh the problem is
she's got nothing to tell maybe she'll
talk about abortion uh but they want her
to talk about infrastructure I don't
know if that's going to go so well but
for a woman who had it handed to her on
a silver platter because she checked off
all the boxes for her to literally fail
in this job is really a sad commentary
on her abilities abortion is certainly
an issue that she is going to push
forward on but Jessica will that be
enough
it really depends who's running in 2024
this is all candidate based and if it's
Joe Biden versus Donald Trump I think
it's going to be fine for the Democrats
we're an incredibly polarized country I
don't think anyone is ever going to have
a landslide but when you look at all of
the data it suggests that Trump if he's
in the race he makes it about Trump and
people have very clear views about that
his die-hard supporters you see him
gaining gaining gaining in the primaries
and falling falling falling in the
general election and Biden picking up
more Independence more Suburban voters
people who could be swayed back by a
more moderate Republican candidate
potentially but this is and if you look
at the NBC approval ratings it's like a
race to the bottom so kamala's approval
rating is higher than Nikki Haley's Mike
Pence's Rhonda Sanchez's Tim Scott's all
people who want to be the Republican
candidate and Donald Trump's net
negative reading makes Kamala look like
the most successful woman in history
it's negative 56 right so this is the
guy who seems to be sweeping the primary
season with you know each new bit of
information about another indictment
coming and last night we all heard audio
of him showing people a classified
document he lied to Brett Bear right he
said there was no document we heard
shuffling of papers and he sounds like a
teenager hey guys isn't this cool look
what I got talking about the nation's
Secrets not a person what about her
though like
it's obviously that she doesn't resonate
with the American public that it's not
whatever is happening right now is not
working I don't know if showing her off
more makes a difference but it all comes
down to what are the names going to be
on the top of the ballot and if Donald
Trump is the name under the R I don't
know if talking about the net negatives
that Kamala has makes any difference
because he didn't know slaves is that
the thing Jessica
obviously his family was slow to a good
business deal or something right but I
think Donald Trump might be more popular
if you know the Department of Justice
wasn't leaking evidence in the middle of
a criminal investigation just think
about all of the terrible things though
that the media can make popular
disco Don Lemon margarine you remember
they had people out there that used to
chant save the whales save the whales
but now the windmills are murdering all
the whales and they're like ah you know
what they had it coming you don't
understand what's going on the media can
Market anything except Kamala Harris and
they have tried and tried and tried
Jessica cigarettes kill people
and cigarettes are more popular than
Kamala Harris
I tried the melon scoop this woman out
of the ticket a couple months ago and
they couldn't pull it off who tried to
melon scoop her we covered it on the
show Jessica Elizabeth
that is the greatest verb it had to be
delicate and what did why did Biden run
he said he was going to be a bridge to
the new generation well that bridge has
blown to Smithereens because the woman
fails under pressure and now he's stuck
with someone as about as popular as
toxic waste would you fly an airplane if
the pilot was old and rickety and the
co-pilot couldn't land it you'd not fly
the plane you drive Nikki Haley hit that
right on the head the other day when she
said that we're not running against Joe
Biden we're running against Kamala
Harris and that sent the White House
into a panic mode and so what they're
trying to do is now every answer out of
this woman's mouth is abortion they'll
ask her about infrastructure it's
abortion abortion abortion that's all
you're going to hear but I'm waiting for
one thing I'm waiting for reporters to
ask Kamala Harris about her boss
extorting foreign Nations for cash props
what she says there will tell you
everything about Kamala Harris and
that's what I'm waiting for you might
have to wait a long time because I don't
think one of those interviews is going
to happen but the Andy Cohen interview
that will happen next time you could
wear something different though me hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else